all right up next is going to be Alex in
California hey Alex how are you doing
very well mr. Ramsay how about you
better than I deserve what's up so my
wife and I got hooked on to your podcast
here we were reading the book that
beyond blessed book was Robert Morris
and he's won over the total money yes he
is and then switched over to the Total
Money Makeover love that and then
turnout about the free app and we live
in the heart of Silicon Valley which
we're at that point and in the area in
the country where we're looking to buy a
home and gone whoa I guess we can get
the little patch over here yeah and here
was the question that we we've decided
through we're somewhere between baby
steps 2 & 3 we have an emergency fund
set up with six months of payments I am
currently in school she is working
full-time we are 23 and 29 and we've
listened to your podcast multiple times
and the running theme was the 15-year
mortgage is what you stand by and the
question is how do we afford a home in
this area with the 15-year well Silicon
Valley is some of the most expensive
real estate in all the United States
right which means when you're a 23 year
old college student you can't afford a
home there you simply can't afford to
live there you don't have enough money I
mean it's just mathematically you just
simply cannot afford to live there I
mean and you cannot afford to drop a
Bentley either and so there's no shame
in that you're just now you're just
where you are you're at the beginnings
of your career so if you rent until
number one let's go back and correct one
thing you don't do baby steps 2 & 3 at
the same time you need to reread Total
Money Makeover you take all your savings
and you put it on your dad until your
debt is gone with the exception of the
fact that your cash flowing finishing
college now when are you going to finish
college about two and a half years good
and your degree is in what Chemical
Engineering okay and you're studying
that where San Jose out of Community
College currently yes sir
yeah and I don't know their way of
learning where are you going to school
yet they're in San Jose okay I was
guessing okay because I didn't think
there's a college to my knowledge of
that type in actual in Silicon Valley
okay but so and you're renting in that
area right now
no sir so the situation was my wife and
I were living with our parents going to
school she graduated we got married we
moved in with my parents
and they have in grace you know gracious
enough to let us live there yeah saving
and scraping everything we can and we've
been feeling that the call it's time to
look look to move on you you know our
own area and it so the options really
for us are renting or buying yeah you're
renting and renting okay now you're
renting for right now because you're
finishing school and getting your
incomes up and again you live in the
most expensive real estate market in the
whole freaking United States with the
possible exception maybe the Upper East
Side in Manhattan
I mean per square foot Silicon Valley is
unbelievable and so it's a wonderful
area but people that make two three
hundred thousand dollars a piece and I'm
both working live they're not college
students with one of you getting and you
just got married and one of you just got
the first job what's your wife make she
we make a household income about 120
yeah she's got a great job what'd she do
she's in business marketing great good
okay that's a great start and see when
you get out with chemical engineering
and you're making 100 and a half so you
got a 270 income or something you know
yeah we can talk about buying a house
and Silicon Valley sorry the number
start to make sense then or at least
closes they're going to and so that's
the direction I would go but but for
today there you haven't done anything
wrong nor is there anything wrong with
my advice when you're 23 year old broke
college student now you're not really
broke you're married to a lady making
120 but but I mean you see my point
you're in a this stage of your life is
the stage that you rent as cheaply as
possible and you know you remember that
horrible
apartment that you tell your grandkids
about someday you know that kind of
that's the stage of life you're in and
the problem is making 120 is actually
still going to put you in a horrible
apartment in your area anywhere else in
the u.s. we would be debt-free in a year
anywhere else in the u.s. you'd be
living in a really nice place you know
but again you live in a high income
neighborhood and a high expense
neighborhood definitely yes so that
that's what we're facing and it's okay
to have the patience to finish up so I
agree with you I want to get out of my
parents house if I were you too but
you're renting for a couple years until
you get your income that matches the
cost of real estate in the neighborhood
that you're in and there's no shame in
that you didn't do anything wrong but no
I would not buy a house you can't afford
a house right now you know the money
you're gonna making 120 you can't really
go buy shanty not that that's what I'd
be in that area I mean just I empathize
and others I know the real estate cost
and what you're dealing with there so
the only other option is a long commute
to school and change the neighborhood
you live in and then you can rinse
something a little better while you're
doing this and talking about a pretty
serious commute because you talked about
some traffic around there that's real
real for sure hey man thanks for the
call five years from now you're gonna be
sitting pretty you're doing the right
stuff